und dieses bild habe ich jetzt endlich
auf grund meiner zahlreichen kontakte
und dem internet nicht gefunden und das
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer aber ich
habe damit sie noch gesucht hallo hier
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft facts heute am dienstag ich
freue mich dass wir wieder eingeschaltet
habe wenn ihr weitere effekt ist die ich
noch nicht vorgestellt habe und wo ihr
denkt wow effekt ist einfach nur extrem
cool
dann werde ich euch sehr verbunden wenn
ich mir die per mail an kontrast
gmail.com senden würde und sonst würde
ich mich freuen wenn ihr bis zum ende
dran bleiben wird und wir fangen
damit fällt nummer perfekt stammt aus
dem minecraft forum minecraft wiki
blabla und zwar besagt der bei der
teleportation werden immer fünf herzen
abgezogen unabhängig davon was für einer
rüstung man trägt zum pferd ist
vielleicht ein bisschen falsch
interpretiert gewesen also fünf halbe
herzen also zweieinhalb herzen das heißt
ich bin hier schon im gaylord 0
neben eine n appel schmeißt sie dahin
und ihr seht sagt zweieinhalb herzen
abgezogen wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal
die diamant rüstung anziehe und ich habe
ihr seht ich habe wieder das leben voll
und ich meine perle darin werden wir
auch zweieinhalb herzen abgezogen auch
wenn ich beispielsweise die perle wo
kann ich wieder hinschmeißen dahinten
trefft dahin treffen treffen achtet auf
die herzen achtet auf die atzen
zweieinhalb herzen abgezogen und jetzt
werde ich natürlich die perle auch
wieder zurück weil ich bin der scanner
und warm und zweieinhalb herzen
abgezogen also immer egal was für eine
rüstung ich habe egal was für eine
entfernung immer zweieinhalb herzen
abgezogen und das war ganz easy effekt
nummer eins zweite fällt wohl mit
zugesendet von doodle unterstrich f und
zwar schreibt er bzw
heiko kräfte vielleicht habe ich einen
neuen weg für dich wenn du ein pferd
anbindet und ist dann tötet er bleibt
die leine da dran
also das ist ein bisschen komisch
geschrieben er hat das auch oder sie
doodle falls ich nicht ganz genau was
jetzt er oder sie es einfach doodle hat
mir geschrieben dass ich eigentlich
einen befehl eingeben muss und zwar
schrägstrich kilb entity horse es geht
allerdings auch anders und zwar habe ich
hier einen zaun hier ein pferd das bin
ich jetzt ganz einfach mit der leine
hier dran an und ich kann jetzt
natürlich ganz normal hier wieder mich
auf das heraufsetzen oder so weiter und
so fort machen ich kann dass die leine
hier abnehmen
kann aber auch sagen ich möchte hier
kommen ich nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
mit ihr fertig da manche die leider so
dass nämlich das feld dann bin ich
wieder erledigt allerdings jetzt das
pferd töte ihr seht nämlich jeder ist ja
diese bolzen um um gewickelt wenn ich
das könnte jetzt hört ihr seht ihr
selbstverständlich die leine dropped
allerdings bleibt sie hier noch dann
wenn ich jetzt richtig drauf drücken sie
einfach weg ich verstehe nicht warum die
dann und dann doch dran bleibt oder so
nicht direkt irgendwie abhaut oder so
wahrscheinlich einfach man tötet das
pferd und dann ist dementsprechend
eigentlich müsste dann so eine leine auf
dem boden liegen aber noch mal kurz den
fag zusammengefasst hier ich habe ein
pferd und pack s hier lernen und ihr
seht schon so ganz normal ich kann deine
wegnehmen dann ist dieser bolzen hier
dieses umwickelte ist ja auch weg wenn
ihr mal links das pferd so töte seht ihr
wie lange gibt weg und ich bekomme die
wieder aber dieser kleine bolzen bleibt
ihr daran das heißt rein theoretisch
wenn ihr das hier extrem cool findet
daran dann einfach einen vertrag
anbieten und pferd töten dann habt ihr
es daran aber nicht mit rechts drauf
drücken weil das wieder weg und das war
ein ganz simpler effekt nummer 2 von
google unterstrich f der gewissen
personen die entweder er oder sie ist
der dritte effekt wurde mir zu gesendet
oder zugesandt ich habe immer noch nicht
den unterschied verstanden von der
minecraft lp 94 heike und ich habe ein
fake für dich und zwar mal kann jetzt in
der 1.8 version wenn man im single
player spielt neben den button wo
schwierigkeitsgrad steht so ein zeichen
dass du den ausgewählten fähigkeit war
blablabla relativ langer text sorry an
dich aber wir sind immerhin zu lange
text um das ganze zu erklären ist es
relativ simpel und zwar können wir die
optionen gehen um mit den texture pack
sieht man den button jetzt gerade ich
das ein bisschen blöd aber sonst so ein
button wo man drauf klicken kann ich
kann mal ganz gut meint eck speck
wechseln dann sehe das so jetzt haben
wir die vom staat und dann seht ihr ich
sehe dieses 1 rast schloss das ist bei
mir eingerastet weil ich das ganze
natürlich schon gemacht habe
diese schloss besagt dass man die
schwierigkeiten nicht mehr ändern kann
das heißt sie bleibt immer auf friedlich
allerdings kann man wenn ihr da außerdem
drauf gekommen seid oder so und ihr habt
die welt nicht gesichert oder irgend
sowas kann man difficulty 0 eingeben
beispielsweise dass die schwierigkeit
auf friedlich gesetzt eingerichtet
wickelt die einst eingeben und ist auch
einfach zwei ist auch normal bereits auf
schwer und wenn ich beispielsweise eine
4 1 gäbe dann geht es nicht weil dann
sagt es mir die angegebene zahl in
klammern viel zu groß sie dafür ist es 3
betragen weil schwer das höchste und
hardcore kann man das ganze nicht mehr
machen und doch kann man jetzt sehen wir
auch was das hier was die geschenke wie
das hier gepixelt aber keine schöne welt
ich würde sagen wie schlimm es nach ganz
einfach mal weg und zwar so jetzt haben
wir
schon das bessere tech speck wieder am
start und dann würde ich sagen was das
eigentlich schon mit fact nummer drei
dass man seine schwierigkeit über ein
command umstellen kann wenn man es außer
sehen in den einstellungen eingerastet
hat der vier defekt wurde mir zugesendet
von jan malte und zwar schreibt er mir
noch ein recht langer text und zwar
sofort möchte das einfach nicht vor
hiess mich erklärt euch einfach mal ein
bisschen und zwar kennt sich pack klar
war immer hier und denke mir ohne
niederlage war muss alles kaputt wasser
daneben und es geht zu ganz normal
obsidian sondern so ganz normal
cobblestone und wird das ganze
eingegrenzt und so weiter und so fort
wenn ich allerdings die lava zum ende
hin einfach mal so aus bringen lasse
also die lava wird jetzt hier immer
größer und ihr wisst schon okay viel
größer kann die aber nicht werden wenn
ich jetzt hier wasser in setzte machte
das wasser da gar nix und auch wenn ich
beispielsweise hier direkt neben wasser
setzte macht das wasser auch nichts also
damit kann es irgendwie lava dich kaputt
machen
ich habe keine idee was nun wenn ich sie
sogar eine plattform höher je was daran
setzen das kommt von oben was ja
eigentlich viel höher ist als die lava
dann blockiert sich das gegenseitig ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt
es wurden auf jeden fall zugesendet von
jan malte wenn ihr den grund dafür kennt
das lager so total boshaft ist wenn sie
in ihrem endstadium es all das hat sie
richtig gefährlich an dann kann sie auf
jeden fall kein wasser mehr bändigen das
ist weil ich mache das wie in einem
actionfilm oder susi kann ihm er
gebändigt werden aber naja das ist auf
jeden fall factory falls man das merkt
aber ich habe kein recht ein bisschen
zeitdruck defekt habe ich zwar schon
gestern abend ausgesucht aber jetzt ist
es schon am nächsten abend und ich muss
gleich wegfahren und a und block und
blau und aber tut mir leid dass die
folge noch ein bisschen stressig ich
weiß nicht freunde letzter zeit ist ein
wurm drin also nicht ein wurm aber es
ist auf jeden fall wird sich das ich in
letzter zeit in nahezu jeder folge als
fünf perfekten bild ein blender und war
seht ihr ein bild wo eine person ein usb
stick ist jetzt fragt was hat es mit
minecraft zu tun und zwar das ist der
grund warum man eier werfen kann in
minecraft ist denkt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich das hast du doch schon
mal vorgestellt ja ich habe schon mal
gesagt dass man minecraft dass man in
minecraft eier werfen kann
weil eine person gesagt hatte haye notch
macht doch mal die eier animation sowie
mit den schneebällen dass man die halt
so wegwerfen kann also dass wir noch
ganz cool mit eiern und so und er meint
in deutschland sondern
weil sie nicht an hat der typ gesagt ich
würde auch einen usb stick essen wenn du
das hinzufügen will dass die regierung
klar dann füge ich hinzu
dann hat er dieses bild hier hochgeladen
und dieses bild habe ich jetzt endlich
auf grund meiner zahlreichen kontakte
und dem internet nicht gefunden und das
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer aber ich
hab damit sie nachgesucht jedenfalls
habt ihr das jetzt eingeblendet hier
schon die ganze zeit und das ist quasi
die person warum du da der wirt zu
verdanken haben dass man in minecraft
eierwerfen kann und guten appetit und
damit würde ich auch schon sagen meine
lieben freunde war es ist wieder zeit
dass es wieder für die fans war es
wieder war war war es wieder damit war
es wieder freunde ihr wisst was ich
meine ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv bei einer bewertung freuen
weil ich immer recht viel arbeit in
dieser effekt folgen strecke wenn ihr
allerdings auch cool effect wisst coole
per mail an kontrast china.com und wir
sehen uns in der nächsten folge wie der
typ ist